being a chemist requires a lot of
creativity really have to put together
disparate knowledge my research is
really focused on the synthesis and
modification of Krypton's some of the
applications for Krypton's have to do
with new types of batteries called
lithium-air batteries and these types of
batteries have the potential to have
storage densities that are as good as
fossil fuels
mit is an amazing place and the
chemistry department was great it was
super collaborative everyone was really
interested in what what projects were
going on and what people were working on
you got to know everybody in the major
so well because it's a smaller major
there's lots of people that you see
every day in class and you make some
really tight friendships course five is
a very eclectic mix we come to course
five for different reasons a lot of
people want to go into research after
like I want to go into medicine I think
what was cool is when i was asking
professors to write my letters
recommendation i realized after I'd
asked all them that not only did they
know me really well and could write for
me really strongly but that I
legitimately really liked them I felt
really comfortable at MIT I also got a
sense of the collegiality among the
professor's Eureka is the series of
twelve laboratory modules that you have
to do to get a degree in course five
each one of them is based on the
research of he experiments the field
that was done by somebody at MIT my
favorite Eureka module is actually the
quantum dot module so that's based on
work of Professor Mooji bawendi and he's
been working on quantum dots for a long
time but we have the chance in module 10
to actually synthesize our own quantum
dots I felt like I learned so much about
the different kinds of chemistry and you
could really appreciate how vibrant this
field is and all the exciting
opportunities available within it and
it's definitely made me I think a better
scientist moving on to the next things
in my career because I was exposed to so
many different techniques there's such a
culture there that is focused on
developing amazing technology but then
also helping to transition that
technology out into the marketplace 2013
we launched TVs that contain quantum dot
materials we switch out the white LEDs
an LED
with blue LEDs and the blue light
excites the red-green quantum dots which
then translates into more vibrant more
brilliant colors so we have magnesium
and we have dry ice and what we're going
to do basically is mix them having a
strong chemical understanding is
something they just don't teach in med
school understanding like how molecules
look like on a three-dimensional scale
like how they can interact with each
other like what reactions look like I
think will serve me really well we
previously made one of these right where
we just got rid of the transcription
activation domain yeah mat shoulders is
professor to my team he's very involved
in what I'm working on this works well
we're really interested in wanting to
understand and learn more about protein
folding inside of a brew live cell
because many diseases are associated
with that so you're going to titrate off
the chaperones on to the unfolded
proteins Nia matter pretty close I
that's cool guy
I like being a violas because it's an
experience that lets me take a break
from the stress and the rigor of MIT
so much what happens in the lab in the
chemistry department you see it other
places like the buckle group for example
their catalysts are extremely popular
and you could just walk you know a few
hundred feet and you'll be in his lab
that's the phenomenal part is that you
have access to these types of people who
really are inventing the future I'm in
the harvard-mit program in health
sciences and technology the project that
I'm working on right now is building an
artificial pancreas for the treatment of
type 1 diabetes the administration in
the chemistry department is so helpful
it was like I was being supported from
every side so getting to this point of
my life like it was my dream but if it
hadn't been for all the people within
the department who are lifting me up to
get me there you know I'm not sure I
could have done it members of the MIT
faculty has helped inspire me in my work
it was really all about interacting with
people that made it rich
you